[Music]
Kelsey you know I was reminiscing today
the first time I met you years and years
ago I was working on the Simpsons and
you came in didn't do the voice of
Sideshow Bob and it's funny because I
hadn't known you in that context and man
I've never seen anyone take to a
character like that man you're built to
be sideshow it was it was meant to be it
was kismet yeah and and it was your your
voice obviously perfect for it but a lot
of Simpsons fans out there they probably
all have competing favorites Sideshow
Bob lines do you have a favorite my
favorite Sideshow Bob line is well Lisa
you don't spend 10 years as a homicidal
maniac without learning a thing or two
about dynamite a dimension to that
character that was uniquely yours which
is he Sideshow Bob
is a homicidal maniac who loves to sing
loves to sing and loves to sing
particular kinds of song well the story
goes honest but the lore behind the
creation of Hyde Shabab involves the
history of my own personal history on
the set of Cheers
I used to sing standards a lot on the
set of chairs because it's just the kind
of hairpin I am and so I'd often walk
into work and you know depending on what
state I was in
but I'd walk in and saying oh you know
take off on that because you know life
is good yeah and Sam Simon who was you
know producing the show at that point
called me that day and said well before
I accepted the job aside Sean said
Kelsey you know you know you used to
sing on the set stuff do you still do
that I said well yeah you know that's
that's who I am and he said what do you
think you could sing the Cole Porter to
mister well of course I could yeah I
mean yeah I mean I love Cole Porter and
then then I you know I kind of put
together this is this idea of this voice
who's really a based upon an old after
named Alice Raab that I'd known I'd used
to work around its apartment and hang
paper over paint bathrooms and stuff
like that he'd sit and tell me stories
late into the night and now let's grab
as much memory to rosemary Harris
some people may know who she's in season
the spider-man movies now it says the
grandmother I guess they have they'd had
a baby she and her husband had a baby
but Alice had been married to her before
the pinellas was gay and it disturbed
him for some reason that she had a baby
with somebody else and there was a
lovely it was a lovely moment when he
said to me that baby could have been
mine and I thought god I gotta I gotta
use that somewhere so sideshow Bob's
voice is really that moment when Ellis
Raab said that to me
yeah so it's wise to him yeah and I
think he you know has his relationship
with Bart as you know he lived he lived
big it was a very serious guy and and he
was very dramatic and I loved him so you
know let me congratulate you on on on
boss
you've got the Golden Globe won the
Golden Globe this very exciting you're
doing something people know you so well
through this other character and you've
done such a good job of transforming
yourself how holds the fan react it's
interesting if some people run up to me
you know they'll say my god that's the
best stuff you've ever done it's
incredible this shows boss it's just
it's amazing that I'll turn a corner and
somebody will go it hey yeah oh you're
that guy hey what are you going back to
television I'm busted by yeah but you
know it's uh it's a cable television in
the world of cable you know no I don't
know you're talking about